good afternoon thank you for joining us
here at four I'm Kirsten joy and I'm
Brian Loftus more than 70 000 people
have benefited from a rental assistance
program in Clark County but that money
is running out there is a deadline
Sunday evening 8 news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy explains from a help
center which many tenants are turning to
more than 500 people came here for help
on Wednesday usually they help about 300
people a day but this increase is
expected to continue as evictions ramp
up it's real scary but everybody's
telling me just to sit tight and we
don't know what's going to happen Derek
Floyd says he's a single father of two
facing evictions
kind of hard to find the job with no
child care and that's been the biggest
struggle with me he tells us he last
paid rent in November received an
eviction notice last year and then filed
an application with the cares housing
assistance program also known as chap on
Sunday night that current program ends
the online application shuts down before
midnight we understand that a lot of
people are currently depending on the
old version of chap a lot of people have
applied a lot of people have exhausted
their chap chap eligibility at this
point so are unable to apply so we do
anticipate more people coming in with
eviction notices Ryan McConnell is an
attorney with the legal aid center of
Southern Nevada which helps tenants here
if you get an eviction notice you need
to file an answer or you could be locked
out within a matter of a couple weeks he
says Nevada is unique because of its
seven-day summary eviction process it's
up to the tenant to file the first
document in a court case after they've
received the eviction notice this causes
an expedited process for evictions Floyd
says while he waits for an answer about
chap he's here to follow his case and
keep a roof over his boy's heads as a
dad you just want to fix it
there's only so much I could do right
now
penny
now in case you need you need to visit
the civil law self-help center it's
located here in the Regional Justice
Center the information desk is right
here once you get through security the
office is right to the left
reporting in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now
the current chap application online
shuts down 11 50 p.m Sunday then a much
more limited version of chap will be
available for extreme circumstances
several qualifications do have to be met
we do have the specifics and more
information about the eviction process
and other resources on our website at
8newsnow.com